also meine These dreht sich um Karl
Lauterbach ich bin fertig mit Karl
Lauterbach das ist auch nicht mehr
rettbar Karl Lauterbach hat
versagt jetzt als Minister im Amt ich
will nur an einen Punkt erinnern
quasi unter seinen Händen ist
ist die Impfkampagne verschieben
gestorben da ist nichts mehr von übrig
hat nichts dafür getan völlig schief
gegangen und er hat ein Problem mit der
Wahrheit das will ich erläutern im
Januar das Erinnern wir alle gut ist ja
die der genesenen Status ganz
überraschend halbiert worden auf drei
Monate die Leute waren entsetzt bei
vielen Leuten war sein schwerer Eingriff
in ihr Leben und dafür haften musste
bislang nur das RKI und dessen Präsident
Lothar villadin waren schuld und zwar
ganz alleine
wenn man sich ein bisschen umtut und
konkreter Recher stellt man aber fest
am 14 Januar hat das RKI diese Anweisung
auf seiner Homepage veröffentlicht am 15
Januar trat sie in Kraft aber am 13
Januar einen Tag vorher schon erschien
Sabine Dittmar das ist die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin von
Karl Lauterbach im Bundestag und
kündigte diese diesen Abbau des
genesenen Status an sie war die erste
überhaupt das RKI kam erst hinterher als
würde das RKI sozusagen die technischen
Einzelheiten verkünden aber sie war die
erste ich will das genau zitieren was
sie da gesagt hat
der genesungsstatus wird künftig nach
den Mond nach nach drei Monaten
beziehungsweise 90 Tagen entfallen
wörtliches Zitat aus ihrer kleinen Rede
sie war so stolz darauf dass sie diese
Rede sogar Homepage bis heute anbietet
der
Bundestagsvizepräsident Wolfgang Kubicki
der die Sitzung geleitet hat hat mir
berichtet den meisten Abgeordneten sei
gar nicht aufgefallen was sie da gehört
haben das passiert ja manchmal das
Rausch zur vorbei jedenfalls hat Karl
Lauterbach die Gelegenheit ergriffen und
bis heute in allen möglichen Interviews
erzählt dass er nichts davon gewusst
habe ich mit ihnen auch wieder wörtlich
zitieren aus einem FAZ Interview da hat
er nämlich gesagt dass der genesenen
Status über Nacht auf drei Monate
verkürzt wurde davon war ich nicht
unterrichtet
ich nenne diesen Satz einen Flirt mit
der Lüge denn wer und das sage ich nur
aus juristischen Gründen so freundlich
ich würde sonst härter ausdrücken denn
wer kann denn annehmen dass eine
Staatssekretärin ins Parlament geht um
diese Botschaft zu überbringen und der
Minister weiß nichts davon da muss man
sich ja die Haare mit dem Fischmesser
kämmen und das zu glauben niemals
außerdem ist Karl Lauterbach bekannt als
einer der Ministerium alles an sich
zieht der nichts an sich vorbeilaufen
lässt und eine Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin hat ausdrücklich die
Aufgabe den Minister nach außen zu
vertreten der wusste nichts ich glaube
kein Wort und nach diesem seifigen
Dementi erleben wir auch noch eine wirre
weitere Regierungspraxis eine
Amtsführung er hat nämlich sofort jetzt
dem RKI die Vollmacht entzogen über
diese Frage zu entscheiden er will
selbst entscheiden nach dem Motto haltet
denn da macht allerdings die Union im
Bundestag nicht mehr mit denn die haben
begriffen dass man diesem Mann nicht
vertrauen darf das haben sie auch sofort
öffentlich erklärt und sie bestehen
drauf dass der Bundesrat künftig an
diesen
unterentscheidung beteiligt wird stoppen
dürfen
auch ein paar Sätze
es wird ja die die also die die der
Bundesrat ist ihm schon in Arm gefallen
nun wird es ja noch wirrer die
die die die genesenen der Spanne ist ja
inzwischen klammheimlich ohne dass da
viel drüber geredet wieder auf sechs
Monate erweitert worden aber nur für die
geimpften die ungeimpften bleiben weiter
auf drei Monaten sitzen wir haben also
eine gespaltene Geschichte und das ist
ja wirklich der Höhepunkt wobei die drei
monatigen ungeimpften das gar nicht in
ihre in ihre Zertifikat eintragen lassen
können in der Apotheke weil das gar
nicht vorgesehen ist das hat eine
europäisches Muster das sieht drei
Monate gar nicht vor so dass wir jetzt
eine Stopp das nächste Mal Stopp Stopp
nein ich muss auch meine Konsequenz
rauskommen ich lasse mich in dieser
freien Sendung auch nicht zensieren das
heißt wir haben
Basismaßnahmen da herrscht jetzt das
totale Chaos und verantwortliches Karl
Lauterbach deshalb sage ich
ich will Karl Lauterbach
nicht mehr erleben wenn im Herbst eine
eine neues Virus über uns kommt dann ich
will auch nach dem Freedom Day am 20
März von Karl Lauterbach befreit werden
der der Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach ist gescheitert er ist
einfach nicht
ministrabel das wollte ich noch sagen so
jetzt könnt ihr also ich stimme in einem
völlig zu das Karl Lauterbach den Sprung
ins Ministerium nicht geschafft hat er
war die ganze Zeit ein großer
Hoffnungsträger und es gab ein riesigen
Druck auch auf Olaf Scholz dass der Mann
Minister werden muss und es gibt in
Deutschland daher so ein gewisses
Vorurteil man muss möglichst vom Fach
sein um Minister sein zu können also am
besten general wird
Verteidigungsminister ist jetzt auch ein
bisschen anders und Karl Lauterbach hat
diesen Sprung nicht geschafft und was
mich wirklich auch stört deswegen stimme
ich dazu dass der WLAN oder Schuldige
ist jetzt mal völlig egal was ich von
den wieder halte das ist völlig
unwichtig aber es ist nun mal so wenn
man Minister ist wenn man irgendwo Chef
ist muss man sich vor seine Leute
stellen und wenn nicht muss man
rausschmeißen und es hat er nicht
gemacht und das geht nicht dieses
Klavieren da stimme ich völlig zu das
geht überhaupt nicht die Hoffnung die in
ihnen gesetzt worden sind nach ihren
Spahn sondern mal ganz nebenbei das war
eine große Koalition und Lauterbach und
sparen waren sehr eng und der war
ständiger Ratgeber war ständig auch im
Ministerium eigentlich gab es diesen
Bruch nicht er wollte was anderes
darstellen und daran meines Erachtens
wirklich bisher nicht gut gefahren ich
finde ja das ist ein bisschen schnell
dass jemand nach drei Monaten gehen soll
für mich ist erledigt ist
momentan ich will ja nur darauf
hinweisen er ist im Moment der
beliebteste Politiker Deutschlands
das müsste eigentlich machen
für mich ist Lauterbach
hauptverantwortlich dafür dass wir einen
fürchterlichen Mentalitätswandel in
diesem in diesem in diesen zwei Jahren
hinter uns haben nämlich zu einem
Obrigkeitsstaat und zu einem regieren
über die Angst und ich muss sagen wenn
mich etwas beunruhigt ist das nicht das
Kuchen tragen in im Innenräumen ich bin
ich bin ich bin grundsätzlich ein
vorsichtiger Mensch ich habe schon
Sagrotan Benutzer wusste die alle noch
gar nicht wie das buchstabiert werden
ich war schon immer vorsichtig aber ich
lasse mir nicht meine eigene Vernunft
nehmen und dass sie mich und ich
entscheide selber wo ich vorsichtig bin
und wo ich zum Beispiel ich bin an der
frischen Luft schon vom Polizisten in
Bayern aufgefordert worden eine Maske zu
tragen ich habe sie natürlich angezogen
und da sofort wieder abgelegt und wenn
ich zwei Schritte weitergehen ich mache
ich möchte ich finde es höchst
beunruhigend dass ein Mann der
hauptverantwortlich dafür ist dass wir
über Angst regiert worden sind sind dass
der plötzlich der beliebteste Politiker
ich mache mir bestimmt so ich mache mir
große Sorgen über den Mentalitätswandel
in diesem in diesem Land ich glaube wir
haben was wir jetzt erlebt haben wir
sind glimpflicht davon gekommen mit
diesen sicher türkischen Virus ich bin
überzeugt dass es werden schlimmere
Krankheiten noch auf uns zukommen in
Zukunft aber wir haben die Generalprobe
als demokratische Gesellschaft nicht
bestanden und das ist für mich nicht
eine Frage der Maske sondern die sondern
die Aufteilung zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften das wird Menschen erstmal
weiter Klasse haben hätte ich nie
geglaubt dass wir sowas geben
genau ja und das gleiche gilt finde ich
auch für die Regelung mit Johnson und
Johnson das hatten wir jetzt gar nicht
besprochen also genesenen Status ist das
eine aber auch das schon zum Johnson nur
mit einer Impfung da hat man die
Auffrischungsimpfung dann gemacht
vielleicht freiwillig weil man sich
gesagt hat ma sollte ich mal lieber
machen und auf einmal gilt der im Status
nicht mehr und man muss sich nicht holen
obwohl es eben noch von einem halben
Jahr hieß Johnson und Johnson ist sicher
sehr wichtig es gibt ein es gibt ein
schleichenden Wechsel zum autoritären
dafür steht auch Karl Lauterbach warum
hat er die Vollmachten an das RKI und
das an das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut
abgegeben weil er vermeiden wollte seine
Pläne in der Koalition mit der FDP
streitig zu diskutieren die hätte ihn
bei manchen denn dann in den Arm
gefallen oder im Bundesrat mit der CDU
also wird das Ganze als
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis ausgegeben
und Wissenschaftler entscheiden darüber
wie wir leben dürfen was ist denn dann
übrig von der Demokratie und also
Politik was macht das Lob gescheitert
gottlos ist ja so dass Wissenschaft
schon eine Rolle spielen soll aber im
Grundlagen parat entscheiden wir ich
finde allerdings für mich mit das größte
Problem bei Karl Lauterbach ist bis zum
Wahltag hat in Deutschland ungefähr
jeder gesagt es wird keine Impfpflicht
geben und noch vor Olaf Scholz war Karl
Lauterbach der gesagt hat Impfpflicht
und das ist für ein Gesundheitsminister
entweder ich sage die Regierung setzt
das durch ich will das durchsetzen weil
sie den entsprechenden Gesetzentwurf
oder ich sage aus der Mitte des
Parlaments dann allerdings halte ich
mich zurück ich meine das trifft für
Olaf Scholz in ähnlicherweise zu aber
für Karl Lauterbach noch mehr denn er
ist Gesundheitsminister und hat damit
natürlich ein sein Autorität eingesetzt
hierher zweifellos hat er ist
medizinisch vermutlich bewanderte als
wir alle aber die darf man eben nicht so
einsetzen
nicht wenn es um eine
Gewissensentscheidung gibt und das ist
das ist wirklich ein großes Problem es
wird immer gesagt dass eine
Gewissensentscheidung und dann darf man
nicht von dieser Position sagen ich bin
für die Impfpflicht und jetzt muss es
auch durchgesetzt werden weil es geht um
den Gesundheitsminister um den Kanzler
es geht ums ganze und das macht
natürlich eine solche Entscheidung
unendlich schwierig ich kann die Leute
verstehen die für eine Impfpflicht sind
ich bin dagegen das ist aber jetzt kann
man diskutieren da soll man einen freien
Austausch eine freie Entscheidung
zulassen und das ist durch ihn behindert
worden und das finde ich nicht zulässig
wenn man so